I think the brand actually was elevated
I would say 60 percentage but I thought
it was 40 yesterday about Twitter spaces
mainstream media musk sax what they're
doing uh yeah those guys those guys
gonna be players obviously this musk is
number one but in the media space
the game changed yesterday 700
000 people are watching this thing and
it crashes but you kiss 700 000 people
live in a room are waiting for this and
they have to go on Sax's account because
musk's 130 million messed up the
algorithm so they went on sax got 650
and it was fine everybody could listen
to everything that was being said and
this the sentence made this announcement
yeah I think I think uh Twitter is going
to be I've said this the day uh musk
bought Twitter I did a video and I said
Twitter's going to be a trillion Auto
Company okay what they're about to do
with Twitter it's scary